[Music]
for many americans for most americans
actually election day is a work day
which can make getting to the polls a
little bit of a challenge
2016 only about 61 percent of americans
of voting age
cast a ballot and that was up from the
previous presidential election
when it was estimated around 58 and a
half percent voted
the u.s reportedly is near the bottom of
32 developed nations in voter
participation in part
because election day is not a national
holiday now some big name companies are
stepping up
stepping in to help their employees chip
reid is at an early voting location in
maryland chip good morning to you
what's it turn out like there well well
i just talked to an
election official here who said in one
word it is astronomical
and in fact records are being shattered
all across the nation and now hundreds
of businesses
are responding to that enthusiasm by
making it easier for their employees
to vote a record turnout record turnout
record turnout numbers with more days
and more ways to vote than ever before
the largest number of americans in
history may have a say
in picking the president but that almost
didn't
include new jersey mom seancine gore
being a single parent especially in
today's time
right people cannot miss work a
trade-off too many
face between going to work to get paid
and taking time
off to vote but this year the only
choice
gore has to make is at the polls the
great thing is we're going to do it
together
as a family and now we get to do that
because we're on all the off work
off work because blue apron the meal kit
service where gore and her daughter
work is giving all 1600 employees
election day off in addition to giving
the day off with pay
we've actually committed to helping with
voter registration
and also transportation to and from the
polls on the day of
blue apron joins more than 2 000
american corporations including apple
walmart and our parent company viacom
cbs
which pledged to provide paid time for
employees to vote
old navy and target are paying employees
to work
at the polls if they want and blue apron
delivered a voter registration drive
at the office we've been very very
specific that we don't want to influence
how
anyone votes we're just giving them all
the tools they need to vote
but for some voters it's still a
struggle just to get in the door
about one in six americans eligible to
vote is disabled
including more than 5 million veterans
it's sad that
veterans go overseas who defend the
american way of life which includes the
right to vote
only to come home as a disabled veteran
and be denied that same right
a right that retired navy seal al kovac
says he was effectively denied in an
election
soon after a parachuting accident left
him paralyzed i went to go cast my vote
and i couldn't even get a parking spot
at the polling station
more than a quarter century after the
americans with disabilities act a
government study found
65 percent of 2016 polling stations that
were surveyed
still had one or more obstacles that
could impede
access for the disabled people see me in
a wheelchair i sense their assumption
that
i'm somehow marginalized as a result of
my disability but
when i place my ballot in the dropbox at
the library i know
that i am having a direct impact on my
country's destiny and that's not
marginalization marginalization that is
empower me
empowerment sean seen gore also feels
with her workplace's
new program um registering people to you
know
actually sending a car service to
someone's house to drive them to the
polls it's just
it's almost like a dream like you just
how could you not vote
like there's no excuses
so far about 81 million americans have
already voted that's about
60 percent of the vote from four years
ago
and we still have four days to go
anthony
chip thank you you do wonder how in the
world's greatest democracy we make it so
damn difficult to vote sometimes thanks